going to turn now to the midterms in
this country and some new developments
in a few key races and we'll start in
the state of Georgia with Senate
candidate Herschel Walker the mother of
one of his children tells the Washington
Post that he wanted her to get an
abortion in 2009 and she had to push him
to pay for it the Republican candidate
who says he is anti-abortion very strict
on the subject publicly campaigned
yesterday with two top Senate
Republicans Nicole Killian is in Atlanta
for us following all this Nicole good
morning they say they're on team Walker
hey good morning to you Tony Herschel
Walker is doubling down on his denials
that he paid for a woman's abortion
although he now says he knows who the
woman is
I know nothing about an abortion
Republicans Senate nominee Herschel
Walker continues to insist reports he
paid for a woman's abortion in 2009 are
untrue did you ever to your knowledge
give money to pay for the cost of an
abortion no
is she lying yes she's lying Walker has
expressed support for a total abortion
ban and was asked to clarify his
position I believe in life no exception
well I believe in in the Georgia
heartbeat bill you know that has
exceptions in it but in a new report
from The Washington Post a woman
claiming to be the mother of his child
says she had to press Walker to pay for
the abortion he wanted she claims she
told him I can't afford to pay for this
and said Walker sent her a 700 check by
FedEx after the procedure you can see
what they're doing the former football
star tried to move on from the
controversy as he teamed up with
Republican Senators Rick Scott and Tom
Cotton Tuesday let's go elect Herschel
Walker to the United States Senate while
their embracing Walker GOP leaders and
strategists are increasingly concerned
his troubles could cost him in the
pivotal Senate race CBS News has learned
what do you say to those in your party
who have concerns Herschel Walker led
the dream of this country he believes in
this country and that's why people are
going to vote for but some voters aren't
so sure there's way too much baggage I
think he could do amazing things for our
Senate
Senate minority leader Mitch McConnell
who wants to express concerns about
candidate quality says he plans to stick
with Walker and speaks with him often a
new poll taken after the Scandal broke
finds that Democratic senator Rafael
Warnock has a slight lead over Walker
Gail
all right Nicole thank you very much